so what what do you call this this is
called what so my name is Kieran hound
and I do pup play pup play is within the
wide world of BDSM and
kink
and I'm also a human yes you are par
doggo so tell me about pup play is is is
this this is a fetish so yes pup play
would be considered a fetish um what I
love about fetish and pup play so it's I
think as humans we're naturally creative
expressive people and we've been like
that for thousands and thousands of
years uh so pup play while it might look
different different and novel and
alternative to people it's really the
spirit of theater so humans going back
multiple cultures thousands thousands of
years have embodied the spirits of
animals whether it's in different
cultures shamanic creatively
Shakespearean theatrical so what I do is
I take the aspects of the canine so
that's playfulness that's loyalty that's
energetic that's love and I channel that
through my human spirit so I make the
canine come alive through my play and
it's it's electrifying it's fun as as a
person I can often be very um heavy and
analytical and serious you know we take
on all this weight as as people we worry
about our bills our jobs our
responsibilities and what ises what does
a dog do a dog's just happy to be around
just wants to play yeah like a dog has
been treated well hi I just met you and
I love you like what's a golden
retriever do everybody loves a dog so
for me what I do with pup play I
consider it like emotional support pup
playing for some within our community
it's a sexual fetish um they love kind
of taking on this mannerisms of like ah
I'm this hot sexy hot sexy dog um and
that's totally valid and beautiful
there's so many ways to express
ourselves but for me
being a very heavy serious person when I
met my first pup
players um was just like I was really
down at the time
and it was a a friend of mine was just
coming out to visit for school and he's
like I met these really interesting
people at this bar and like I'm stay
with them come on over and I knew about
BDSM and kink a little bit through
actually seeing Pony play which was like
taking on the spirit of the horse and I
was like I grew up with animals I love I
love that theatrical playfulness but I
saw these two guys that just had little
dog tags on their neck and I was like
wait are y'all pup players and they went
from like this to like oh my God yes
we're pup players like hi oh my god do
you want to come hang out with us do you
want to come to our puppy party I was
like what's a puppy party they're like
well we get all our friends coming over
and we're all pups and anytime somebody
came to the door everybody ran to the
door barking to welcome them in I was
like it was the cutest thing i' ever
seen and I learned there was a community
for it I learned there were contests for
it where it's it's just like the most
beautiful silly thing it's like taking
this serious stateliness of say like you
know Miss Universe or like Miss America
we like okay it's very vanilla is you
have you have gowns but you know you
have the wave you have a platform it's
taking like that structure of being a
good Ambassador leader but wrapping it
in with BDSM and King Community where
how do you help people bring out their
own inner play and light so often when
we see people really dressed up big and
fancy even if we don't understand it I
think there's always a part of us that's
kind of almost like I don't have The
Bravery to do that but I kind of wish I
did but there's there's something
interesting and pulling about it so I
think when whether it's whether it's pup
play or whether what any of us do when
we really when we embody that joy in
which we find we kind of give permission
to other people to like be creatively
expressive as well and so it's also a
joy practice it's very near and dear to
my heart it helps me alleviate um
anxiety it helps me alleviate um
depression that I deal with and I've
just met so many beautiful lovely people
through it and I love to talk and share
about it and Chase toys cuz who doesn't
like who doesn't like squeaky toys it's
just it's great well you can't argue
that there's there's probably not
another creature on earth that is as
loving and playful as as as dogs are
absolutely and you know if you really
consider if we if we all could be a
little more like dogs the Earth would be
a better place yeah and we've I think
about too how as humans have evolved
we've evolved thousands of years along
sides dogs like there's a reason if you
actually see video of how a dog reads a
person's face like we've they can read
points of how the human emotes and so
sometimes people when they think of pup
play they're like that's really weird
like you're not actually a dog or you
think you were born into a dog person
they like I don't know it there's only
so much you can tell from like trying to
look at pictures on the internet to
understand anything it's
this yeah it's a theatrical art how I
explain it to people people understand
what human theater is you have an actor
or an actress who understudy a character
historical whatever now they don't they
don't actually think they're that person
with taking on costuming with taking on
mannerisms roles accents they make that
person come alive on screen and so
people suspend disbelief for a while to
kind of enjoy this character and so I do
that but with the spirit of the dog so
it doesn't have anything to do with
playing with real
dogs that's a weird shadowy side that
sometimes people think no people don't
sexualize real dogs um I grew up myself
uh I'm an only child and I grew up with
uh AAS qu hounds Dalmatians American
Eskimos dogs were always very much like
my siblings that I never had and I was a
very kind of shy nervous kid and I
didn't really understand how why how and
why people peopled but there was
something there was a a calm Resolute
strength and elegance and foundational
power about dogs and cats and animals so
I think part of me from like a young age
I was like I just intuitively understand
this this mannerism and this way of
talking because animals really they talk
to us all the time not through English
not through words but through their
their energy their body mannerism yes
sometimes louds you know loud bark
they'll definitely let us know
um but there's something very pure about
that that I just I love that people
intuitively connect with as well is it
is it
just a way of like connecting and
playing with others that's that's a
little
more like in the style of a dog that
it's just more kind of free and open and
found foundationally for me yes cuz
because you as you said earlier it's not
sexual it's not sexual it is for some
but not absolutely not for you um and
it's to me also it it very much depends
on how you can Define sexual you know in
the US we live in a very uh sex phobic
culture so some people will see somebody
showing a little bit of shoulder and be
like that's really risque that's very
sexual it's just a shoulder um all the
way scanning to okay well you have
penetrative sex in porn it really
depends on how somebody defines it so
outfits themselves like gear is not
always sexual and I would actually say
it depends on the person how they're
expressing themselves so yes I so being
a part of the pup Community which is a
subsect of BDSM and kink it also has um
much foundational history in the lgbtq
queer Community um Kink has been a
radical way of kind kind of taking back
ownership of very creative sexuality and
creative
expression and it's also important for
like me to to honor that history it's a
yes people make it their own but there's
also a lot of tradition in this like we
go back to the the dogs personality dogs
also usually have jobs if they evolved
along people they love being of service
you know you have working dogs you have
search and rescue dogs you have service
dogs
and pups or pup players or pups as
they're known um often have like a long
history some people can be in power
exchange relationships with Partners so
say like they might have an owner or a
master um or a Dom just totally depends
on the person um me personally I've just
loved kind of being a community service
pup so I've never had an owner partner
um I just kind of like to be that almost
like the if there was a big party of
people I'm kind of like the house dog or
I just like to go up to everybody kind
of maybe beg for snacks but you know I
don't I'm not owned by anyone it's not
so you have you have gett togethers with
other pop players yes um in La we're
we're very fortunate to have a very rich
community so at at different bars and
Gatherings there's ways that people
congregate and come together to kind of
just beyond the understanding level
there's so many different types of hoods
so there was like the hood that I was
wearing earlier um there's many
different styles some people love the
anonymity of it they just really want to
get into that head space where they
nobody knows who they are outside of a
bar space and that's that's awesome um
they keep the the face covering on right
yeah and I think and that's beautiful
because you know we have to be real that
still a lot of this alternative
expression of
sexuality can put some people at risk
there's a lot of people that say like if
they work in like very very conservative
Industries or conservative
families sees this as something so weird
and deviant and dangerous that like
maybe they're not safe now obviously
this is a gross like way out there gross
overgeneralization but people have to
meet themselves where they're
comfortable
now your your earlier comparison of
comparing this to an actor on a
stage what's the difference exactly so
for I mean for me when I do pup play
it's just like another beautiful hobby
of mine so say like if somebody really
loves the LA Dodgers and they love
getting out on Dodger blue and they love
going to the games and they're just
crazy fan and they have other favorite
players they're probably not in that
outfit all the time time they have a job
they have you know uh rup Paul famously
said like we're all born naked and the
rest is drag these are all costumes
different costumes and so I don't live
247 doing this it's just it's a joy
practice I love bicycling I do fire
spinning I go to Burning Man events I I
love how we as humans just creatively
can dress and take on a whole different
Persona so it's it's a different way to
spark deep conversations with people and
I mean look at Nature Documentaries if
all the animals in the world were all
this colored the same and dressed the
same it'd be so boring but whenever you
think you might be too weird just watch
like a deep sea documentary and see the
things that come out of the water and
you're like I haven't even begun to be
weird I'm just getting started I'm just
going to take notes from the things that
come out of the deep and be like oh man
I could never be that weird
but and you have a job I do you have a
fairly conventional life outside of I do
yes I I went to college I have a ba in
Communications um I was a j i was a
newspaper journalist for many years I've
what actually really helped me um being
interested in Communications and
journalism was I feel like animals
raised me in a lot of ways like I under
I started understanding energy and how
people use their body language I'm like
okay I understand
that but the understanding how to deeply
relate with people being able to
interview so many different people in
very small towns um across Georgia was
like oh wow okay and actually at the end
of the day it doesn't matter what type
of job title you have or how much money
you have if you're currently
experiencing homelessness if you're
currently the mayor
or there's a deep energy within us all
that we really just want to be feeling
safe we want to be accepted we want to
be celebrated we want to just we want to
be validated by people and when I kind
of started learning that especially in
my early 20s before I learned about Kink
before I knew anything that I was like
there's something really soft and
special about this that it's easy for
people to forget when we when we get in
our little bubble of like this is my job
title this is my name this is what I do
I can't deviate outside this bubble it's
like you still can that that energy that
we have of you know this is who I am
it's not
defined by our name by our job title
we're much larger than that in the
cosmos and so I can get I can get very
philosophical about pup play uh Karen
what was what was your childhood like
how how did you grow up uh well when an
egg meets a sperm
um after that yes after that um
so being interested in stories I think
about my foundational patterning of my
childhood a lot
so I want to preface this by saying I
have so much immense respect for parents
and those who raise children it is not
an easy job especially if it's like your
first child everybody's learning as they
go so even though I don't have a child
myself
I'm coming through a point in therapy
where I want to be honest about what I
remember going through and
experiencing but I'm also trying to come
from a kind compassionate place where
I'm not
judging people for doing it right or
wrong because that's that's not the
energy in which I want to cultivate
going forward so that being
said uh I I'm 36 years old I was born in
just north of Dallas
Texas um parents are from the Northeast
so I'm a little bit of a a mix between
northern and southern
sensibilities and my
childhood I'm an only child
and I believe that my parents I always
had I'm very grateful for the physical
stability I had always had food on the
table had a roof over my head I'm so
grateful for that but I also realized
that I grew up in a lot
of emotional
instability um there was an immense
amount of passive aggressiveness uh
screaming yelling uh
threats
um and I think that's probably what
caused me to be a very quiet introverted
kid for so long um but I've just kind of
learned of like again somebody can
actually be very violent and angry and
actually still be doing the best that
they can within the knowledge that they
have and so I love my parents very
dearly but it's uh and I'm grateful for
what I had but I'm just now kind of
realizing now in my 30s going through
therapy um
until I moved out finally moved I mean
at college for a while but when I
finally moved back and I moved out and
when I was 27 I was walking on eggshells
really for like 27 years um I never knew
when if like I'm five or six years old I
would leave a cup out and my dad would
just break into screaming demeaning at
me of like you know you're always you're
always going to going to mess up you're
nobody's ever going to want to hire you
you're never going to do anything
right and when you hear that from a
young age you can't reason of oh my
parent is having an
emotional like flashback transgression
probably to their own childhood no like
as children we absorb everything and
there's a very strong narrative in me
that I have to battle every day that has
that internal monologue of I'm always
doing something wrong there's always
something wrong with me and that
probably led to a lot of my anxiety and
depression and with um an important part
of my pup play too is yes being an
emotional support pup player but I also
call it being a being a guard dog and
being a protective guard dog about
people it really has foundations
so when I was 5 years
old um
the house of my great-grandmother was
being
renovated and my family had hired a crew
of people to help renovate the house
during the day and we were staying in
the house and I was with the family
member we're staying in the house
overnight and for whatever God knows
reason two of the guys came back at
night they cut the power to the house
they cut the phone line they broke
in and and they raped my family member
in front of me when I was 5 years old
and I remember screaming at the foot of
the
bed and screaming for a long time
and
I have what I'm realizing is I
actually it's been
now 31 years and I think about that
every single day I replay that in my
head every single
day and I'm very proud of my family
member for not only
surviving but God knows what they had to
do and what they were thinking to
protect me cuz they probably didn't know
what these guys were going to do
possibly to me uh when they left they
stole our car and they torched it down
the road and so one of my earliest
memories from childhood was going going
into the police station they brought our
charred car in and I had a a little
Beanie animal named Pumphrey it was like
a little leopard and I had a plastic
bangle around it and it was like my my
best friend and it was charred in the
back of the car and I just remembered
like the smell of charred car and I
picked up Pumphrey and he just fell in
two and all the the beans just fell
everywhere and I also think about that
every single day and I think why this is
so foundational to me even as like a
young
child a police officer came to me and
was
like you did so good for screaming so
much because they probably left a lot
sooner than they wanted
to and you
know I'm not I'm not angry at the
officer for saying that you know what do
you say to a 5-year-old that just went
through something horrifically traumatic
and um but I think in this small way it
laid a point
of I know you can't do anything at 5
years old to protect much any you're
just trying to
survive but within
seeing
such like a a close Focus that I would
have with dogs growing up that I was
like there's some dogs that that are
protectors they they protect they're
human I want to be able to do
that like what what if what if we had
had a dog that could have been a
protector that could have been there
what would that look like what would it
look like if I
embodied this energy if I grow an
awareness if I learn how to read people
that I could possibly help someone to
avoid a situation like
this so
that's that's a burning core
memory and also like a trauma point
where I'm like yes it
happened but what I've Loved learning in
the last couple years is trauma isn't
what happened to us it's
what we made it mean because of it so I
can't change what happened in the past
but I can change my relationship to
it so it's made me very intensely
interested in human psychology now the
two men that did this they were children
once they were my they were they were 5
years old
once what happened to them in their
life that caused their humanity and
their psyche to be twisted in a way in
which they thought this was a valid idea
to do now those those those two men were
caught and there was a trial I one day I
would actually really like to know their
names I'd really like to be able to
actually meet and talk with them one day
I don't know their names and maybe
that's one day for me to find and
discover more but it's made me deeply
interested in the nature of
trauma um all of us experience either
you know big tea or little tea traumas
that was obviously a big tea trauma for
me um but how do we you know when when
we're born into the world as as pups or
humans
um we just we absorb
everything around us we're just the the
environment shapes us and if we were all
raised in validating safe nurturing
ways why would the psyche go to a place
that would harm somebody because
somebody doing that is not doing
themselves any favor there's
something deeply off and in wrong
they're they're in horrific pain and
what I've learned is to more often than
not they're recreating a pain that
somebody did to them they were taking
advantage of at some young ages so in
their desperate attempt to feel some
type of control in the world
they become their own abuser and they
abuse other people and this is how
intergenerational trauma happens it's
not because they were born bad
people something so horrific once or
several times happens that actually it
becomes this very Twisted coping
mechanism for them they're just trying
to feel normal and I would actually
argue this happens at the same time with
people who struggle with addiction I
have um a lot of addiction in my family
um pills alcohol um I'm approaching 5
years of alcohol sobriety
myself and what's helped me just why
like find normality in in pup play but
also just in life is it's not why the
addiction it's why the
pain and so when I'm in these spaces in
in pup play in in queer spaces in Kink
parties yes people are dressed up
fabulously and they look great in their
leathers and we're all very sexy
mysterious but I think life has shaped
me and cultivated my energy in a
way where I'm the emotion I mean there
can be several but I'm an emotional
support pup in my community so people
know that if they're struggling with
something I'm a person they can go to to
feel
heard now that doesn't mean I still have
my own work to do my own traumas and
sometimes I mess up sometimes I'll say
something that is callous or not helpful
it doesn't mean that I'm holier than
thou than anyone else um but I just try
to work of like again what's my story
how do I own it how can I be accountable
how can I be the best person that I can
be and then again I look to the spirit
of the dog when I when I just get in my
head and I'm overthinking
everything go down to
Basics are you facing someone are you
giving them your heart and attention a
dog can be one of the absolute best
therapists in the world just by being
around they don't have to say anything
so sometimes what we just want as humans
is just somebody to just be with us to
sit with us in our pain and one of my
one of my life goals is to become a
therapist I want to become a marriage
and family therapist I want to become a
part of a solution of help not fixing
people because nobody nobody can fix
someone else and do it for it but if
you're honest and authentic with the
stories that shaped you and what you've
learned along the way and you can help
talk to people about
patterning and help remind people of
their own inherent power to connect to
themselves I think that's just
absolutely
revolutionary and that's a that's a
universal connection power outside of
you never have to put on a costume you
could wear a white polo and CAC for the
rest of your life and you're
still just as beautifully connected and
Powerful as anyone else it's not a
popularity contest no matter how fancy
we
look so that's what I love about pup
play and how it teaches me and pup play
teaches me to be a better human really
does what would what would you say
Kieran is the most interesting lesson
that we learned from from
dogs or that you've
learned
dogs are very tied to their
intuition
so humans yes for all our fancy
development in upper cognitive
development in our language
unfortunately our brains can also talk
to us so when we're born we're purely
intuition we can't hide our emotions
like try to tell a two-year-old child to
reason out of what they're feeling ain't
going to
happen dogs in a way are like this as
well they're purely tied in to the
community if they get a bad Vibe about
someone you're not talking the dog out
of that vibe they're going to bark
they're going to keep their distance
dogs and intuitively feel safeer on
other
people we have that same intuitive sense
in us as people but often times because
of trauma or our big brains we'll talk
ourselves out of it but we end up paying
the price how many times have you had a
feeling that I'm not feeling quite right
about it but I'll do it anyway and then
you regret
it that's because of a pattern that you
learned in childhood in which you Wen
weren't safe and you weren't validated
so you had to like you had to suppress
that dogs remind us in a way that we
don't have to suppress that we can be we
can be authentic and true to
ourselves and a simal person that it's
funny not in the Kink World um but Dr
Gabor mate who speaks beautifully
eloquent about the nature of trauma
human
development has so inspired me to look
at the world differently like that so
it's not really a kink counselor but I
would say a lot of people who do Kink
and pup
play are so curious about just like the
nature of themselves that they want to
get deep into relationship with people
and Communications to get really
ultimately it's about reconnecting to
ourselves through being open with other
people and dogs are the most perfect
example of
that they just they just want love they
are love and I think they remind us
they're really at our core no matter how
many flaws that we've picked up that we
flaws that we think we have that we've
picked up along the
way they remind us that we're also
love and that's what I want to embody in
the world and I'm grateful
for everyone who's also shined the light
with me when I get when I get sad and
I'm like a sad puppy my community they
pick me up and they remind me of that
and when I'm just around dogs it's just
like happy ruffle on the head and I'm
like it's going to be okay we're going
to be
okay that's what I love
beautiful all right Karen thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you so
much Mark I really appreciate it and
we'll love ourselves and we'll go out
and love the
world thank you very much thank
you